I am a big fan of one punch man but
oddly enough despite its massive surge
in popularity I haven't seen the other
super hit from the prolific author of
one punch man entitled mob psycho 100
this is a show with a main character
that has the same face as one punch man
saitama is animated with a degree of
Polish the likes of which don't even
reside within my dreams and is about uh
psychics and ghosts I think I'm honestly
not too sure about that last one and
that concludes my summary of the
knowledge I have in my brain concerning
this series I'm serious I know nothing
else about this story so this one should
be interesting to explore with fresh
eyes and given that the series is
officially finished there's no better
time than right now to review the anime
the manga the music and the behind the
scenes production of this massively
successful series will I enjoy this
series more than I enjoyed one punch man
will it live up to the Whirlwind of hype
surrounding it when this video is done
what will I think of mob psycho 100.
[Music]
alrighty so this isn't a long series by
any means the manga is only 16 volumes
long and it is the single most
interesting manga I've ever wanted to
take a look at as I'm sure many of you
are aware one unlike many other popular
mangakas of the modern manga scene
doesn't exactly have a conventional
artistic style wouldn't might expect
from someone that's accrued such
enormous success across the world I
think that's honestly fascinating and
speaks to the characters he's created
and endearing drawings he's grown a
substantial following with and so to be
clear I'm not discounting the original
manga in fact while I will be placing a
hefty amount of emphasis and attention
to the gloriously produced anime I have
always been curious to see the source
material from which the studios draw
inspiration and guidance from unlike one
punch men which received the red carpet
treatment by being redrawn by yusuke
Morata possibly the best artist in the
business right now mobs manga is one's
original artwork for all of us to enjoy
raw unfiltered and entirely true to his
vision of the story and so because of
that I'll be curious to explore how or
if his original version has been adapted
compromised or enhanced by the vehicle
of this incredibly impressive looking
anime in this video I plan on analyzing
The Source manga from one I want to
dissect the music of this series as well
as break down its incredibly healthy
production and development behind the
scenes and that's not even to mention
this crazy story and episode 1 seems
like a great place to start
[Music]
I've sat down and I've watched all of
mob psycho 100's first season and this
show is amazing this unironically might
be my new favorite anime ever uh yeah
I'm gonna spend the next I don't know
half an hour 40 minutes how much is on
the clock talking to you about how it's
made why it's so damn good and why I've
never seen a show like this okay here I
go the introduction unlike Attack on
Titan one piece or Naruto unlike JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure or even Hunter Hunter
mob psycho 100 opens its narrative with
no clear story or path forward instead
the first three episodes or so deal with
singular events self-contained stories
of sorts that act as a mechanism to
primarily introduce us to the key
characters of this story in other words
it doesn't give us an obvious narrative
reason to keep watching like Dragon Ball
did with I gotta collect all the dragon
balls or like Attack on Titan did with
we gotta get across the walls and
freedom and all that kind of crack right
and yeah mob psycho 100 doesn't really
do any of that at least not in any
obvious way and to be honest normally
when it comes to stories that start off
without establish pushing a clear-cut
goal they tend to lose me quickly
however there was something about this
series that felt different normally I'm
waiting for a narrative through line to
hold on to when I start watching or
reading something but when it comes to
One's best work the author of both one
punch man and MOB psycho he actively
tries to fight against that and I think
it helps to reinforce what his work
stands for Mob psycho 100 much like one
punch man despite having wildly
different main characters represents a
Fantastical world with plenty of
over-the-top even silly gag humor the
goal here is to make us laugh and it
more than definitely succeeds in that
effort however as is the case with one's
work and his most popular characters in
saitama and MOB himself while we might
see these stories they occupy as being
silly or over the top these appearances
are designed by one to be deceiving
foreign
in other words there's always more to
these characters and these stories than
what initially meets the eye how a
character is revealed to us oftentimes
tells us a lot about their personality
in the case of saitama in one punch man
he's very quickly depicted as the
world's de facto superhero before
moments later blowing away the monster
in an instant it is only later we find
out that he is largely an unknown doing
it because he wants to such is the
subversive nature of one punch man mob
psycho while similarly subversive takes
an entirely different but similarly
appropriate approach unlike saitama who
was depicted as this impressive
impactful and domineering superhero
that's there to save the day mob psycho
opens by introducing Reagan a smooth
talking largely good-natured con artist
pretending to be psychic For Hire he is
mob's boss and while he is a supporting
character mob isn't even the second or
third character introduced in his own
story and how the anime decides to
introduce him is honestly I think
ingenious as I will soon explore a
driving theme within mob psycho 100's
narrative is that of manipulation and
deceit how others can use people to get
ahead in this world and the philosophy
that comes with those that choose to not
leverage their position to put down
others in the first episode Reagan
accepts a job to exercise a ghost fails
to do so because
of course he does and then resorts to
calling on Mob someone who actually is
talented and has the skills necessary to
deal with this exorcism he is the fifth
character introduced in his own story
and when he is introduced it's because
Reagan needs him unlike Reagan who
exploded onto our screens with plenty of
Charisma and energy or the dramatic and
silly seeing the couple he's dealing
with had or even the grand entrance the
ghost made instead of all of that mob is
introduced from afar as a card that
already looks like it's part of the
background pulls out of the way
revealing some unassuming shy Wallflower
the likes of which look more
unremarkable than any other character in
this series this is a perfect
introduction to mob as a character and
everything from his design introduction
even voice actor was measured to reflect
that specific sense of normality
surrounding him where saitama eventually
flashes onto her screen after a dramatic
build up mob on the other hand looks
aggressively unimpressive that is until
foreign
our attention away from the
action-packed set pieces of the first
couple of episodes this Choice pays
dividends and we begin to understand
more why this direction for the
character was chosen we see him in
school and in his day-to-day life we see
his relationship with his parents and
brother how he's failing both
academically and physically and how he
is no friends inside our outside of
school to speak of reflected in the
first episode's closing but sweet and
somber scene that reinforces the
relationship he has with Reagan as mob
looks on at others chatting and
exchanging life experiences before
happily returning back to Reagan's side
the closest person mob has to a real
friend inviting him to share dinner
outside of that the series due to its
muted and somewhat passive main
character creates a rather large vacuum
of Charisma to be filled and so I
present to you the king of Riz Reagan
[Music]
the brief description I offered of
Reagan paints him like an awful person
and while he sort of is in his own way
due to the way the character is written
it depicts a more roguish character than
a complete reprehensible one so much so
that he pretty much steals the show if
you don't pay close enough attention in
these opening episodes and indeed
through to the end the fashion with
which he's able to disarm what would
otherwise be a dangerous or jailable
offense with his gift of conversation is
a fascinating superpower I've not seen
presented in a more entertaining way on
the page or Silver Screen in years
Reagan is a once in a generation type of
character and he must be protected at
all costs
at this point there's a lot of conscious
artistic choices being made like the
voice actor and the animation so I want
to touch on that for just a second
because they really help to elevate this
particular Direction the Story decided
to go in bringing this show to life from
such a unique Source material is a
challenging task no matter the
experience or age of the director
involved in bringing it to life and when
I found out that the series was adapted
by director yuzuru tachikawa in his late
30s I was blown away however he did have
an impressive resume to his name outside
of working for prolific Studios like mad
house and Studio pero he's directed The
Beloved death Billiards and death parade
anime featured on killer kill and Attack
on Titan and also co-directed Terror in
resonance with the legendary shinichiro
Watanabe of none other than Cowboy Bebop
Fame and through doing so built up a
huge reputation for himself and by
extension an extensive list of talented
friends from which he was able to draw
from to work on Mob psycho 100. I
mentioned earlier that mob appearing a
certain way in this anime was a
necessary part of the story and so oh I
think this quote from author one on the
subject of adapting his manga was rather
Illuminating he said the only thing I
asked the staff to do was to keep the
anime's mob looking as close to the
original as possible but other than that
I'd rather an adaptation have some
character to it than be a slave to the
source and through interviews we can see
as clear as day that tachikawa the
series director took the original work
extremely seriously and this rather
serious and dedicated approach to the
source material is clear from the get-go
mob psycho 100's animation style
approach and philosophy largely runs
counter to the standard practice of the
modern animation industry in Japan it
shuns CGS instead falling back on
hand-drawn vehicles and Interiors all in
the name of giving this series an
old-school flavor and to that effect the
legendary yoshimuchi kameda came in as
character designer renowned for his Inky
and snappy animation across an endless
number of shows like Fullmetal Alchemist
Space Dandy and of course one punch man
and in this first episode it's clear as
day that he leads this outing his work
is the core Foundation of mob's visuals
sketchy lines Dynamic and exaggerated
facial expression Snappy gesticulations
it's all coming out to its core he is
quite a strict supervisor but with
Talent like this it works and keeps
things alive consistently which is
wonderful because the first episode
bounces around from scene to scene
encounter after encounter and without a
consistently fun and expressive design
and animation philosophy such as this
conversations such as those which Reagan
engages in might not hit the high as the
anime otherwise succeeded in reaching
this choice of initially and
predominantly depicting mob as an
aggressively mediocre and mundane
Schoolboy was a measured but conscious
effort and as it happens setsuo the
actor who voices mob in the anime is a
complete newbie and when asked about
this Choice tachikawa had this to say I
wanted mob to have a voice nobody would
recognize I wanted the voice actor just
like mob himself to be someone
relatively unremarkable we had a huge
number of candidates for the role but in
the end ito's voice most fit my idea of
mob and so I hope this brief analysis of
the series's opening helps to shed some
light and why I don't mind that the
series didn't open with a clear
narrative golden mind because it does
seem to have a vague narrative goal mob
has expressed to some degree a desire
that is outside of the one vertical he's
particularly exceptional at he's weak in
others and he wants more he wants
connection he wants what the everyday
person has and him being this
exceptional person doesn't seem to
matter if you have nothing else and I'm
interested and invested now in seeing if
he has the will to make this a reality
for himself and most importantly how
these obstacles and emotional stressors
contribute to one of the most
interesting mechanics used in this
narrative the inclusion of a percentage
meter counting up to 100 which
represents an explosion of sorts this
naturally creates anticipation and over
the first three episodes as we build
towards the eventual explosion we're
anticipating we gain a familiarity with
the aspects of his life that actually
trigger this metaphorical leader to rise
closer and closer to a boiling point in
episode 2 Bob's introduced to a concept
of seizing the day because someday there
might not be any time left to seize and
through that episode he's being pulled
in two separate directions by two
different parties that both want or need
something from him explicitly the
telepathy Club threatened with
abolishment from the class president due
to lack of interest and then there's of
course Reagan who without mob would lose
the only tangible asset that grants his
business legitimacy at the end of the
day this is the story of a young man
being pushed and pulled emotionally in
two opposing directions neither of which
have his best interest at heart and
makes the conclusion of this tale all
the more satisfying what he chooses
quite bravely to step outside of his
comfort zone choosing neither easy
option offered to him and instead
chooses the path of self-improvement
with low-key my favorite group in this
entire show the good gym Bros they are
amazing
the third episode however is where we
get a taste of what exactly we've been
building to and Mob In Action is
outstanding and this crazy musical
instrumentation that plays when he uses
his powers is incred wait I haven't even
talked about the music okay music I
don't think I need to say anything about
this op it's easily one of the most
gorgeously stylized Ops I've ever come
across brought to Reality by comeda he
apparently took inspiration for this
opening's animation from the music video
by Miyavi entitled afraid to be cool a
momentary glance is all you need to see
the neon City element from the op was
heavily inspired by it but in terms of
Music the theme song Not only fits the
series perfectly counting to 100 with a
building swirling Rhythm before
devolving into a crescendo of
instrumentation at the end but it is
also the only song I've ever heard for
the very first time that I immediately
loved and in tandem was able to sing
along to because I of course count to
100. Humble brag in terms of the broader
series though one of the most fantastic
musical additions to the story comes by
way of how they utilize certain musical
themes a musical theme in this context
is the primary piece of melodic
information within a piece of music
which can but doesn't have to represent
a narrative concept take the Imperial
marriage by John Williams in Star Wars
that represents the evil of the Republic
or hedwig's theme from Harry Potter that
represents places of safety and courage
however this psychic theme of mobs is
out of this world and I have to talk
about it
if there's one single thing that the OST
for this show achieves the one element
that I would argue is the most important
it's it's carving out of a unique sound
identity for itself from day one people
often don't give music The Narrative
credit it deserves and there really is a
story that can be told through music
that I want to get into right now
because this soundtrack is incredible
between the unique instrument used for
mob's theme the off-kilter traditional
drums and strings that are peppered
throughout mob and Reagan's lives and
the common but fascinating use of
microtonal and Out Of Tune instruments
everywhere gives me a ton to explore
when it comes to analyzing music but mob
psycho 100's composer Kenji Kawaii
establishes an unmistakably immersive
and unique soundscape to the series that
both cements its distance from the
contemporaries as well as wonderfully
serves the characters and atmosphere of
the show and yes you heard me right he
uses off-key micro tonal music and boy
is it everywhere in this score so why
does he choose to use out of key
instrumentation at times well as a quick
and nerdy background for those
uninitiated in traditional Western
musical Theory there are 12 notes in a
scale this is what 98 of the notes you
hear in any given month are made out of
microtonal notes on the other hand are
notes in between the 12 notes in our
Western scale so in this track found in
episode 3 many of the notes are
microtonal that is to say slightly flat
or sharp of notes that we would be used
to hearing and this use of off-key and
microtonal notes in the show score Rudy
does an extreme amount of lifting in
giving the music not only a unique
unmistakable flavor compared to other
anime but also I think serve to
communicate the awkward stilted Vibe of
mob as a character in this story
narratively this theme is practically
the musical representation of mob's
character in the musical score it's off
tune in the same way that Bob is sort of
out of place in his real world he
doesn't fit in anywhere just like these
notes and that's such a wonderfully
inspired musical idea in episode 3 The
Story la largely deals with mob being
misled into a cultist gathering which
facilitates our introduction to the
Troublesome and power-hungry spirit
known henceforth as dimple the explosion
however that takes place towards the
conclusion of episode 3 is an almost
terrifying and otherworldly scene to
witness take shape before us there are a
set of themes in this soundtrack that
are related to the stress that mob often
feels preceding his explosions and the
one used in this episode is downright
terrifying entitled toram if you didn't
know anything about this show you'd
assume that this sense of Terror is
meant to be pointed towards the scary
ghost brainwashing the masses in dimple
but as onlookers we of course understand
that it is in fact likely pointed
towards what sort of terrifying thing
may happen once mob reaches 100 and
snaps
oh
these opening episodes offer us our
first glimpse into how scary mob psycho
100 could be from the emotional state of
mob clear for us all to see to the music
used to the animation to the storyboard
and doesn't even to mention some of the
more obscure artistic Expressions
otherwise seen in this anime that give
the series its otherworldly feel paint
on glass animation is used all over this
series and comes straight from Miu Sato
and add such an unusual almost ethereal
possessive Sinister atmosphere to the
animation for certain more intense
scenes and the series ending animation
and it is utterly perfect for a series
like mob psycho 100 episode 3's
animation is led by goze Oda and ex dude
Ghibli in between artists who gained
substantial connections at Studio bones
after leaving he's very much well known
for his animation that isn't hugely
concerned with detail but instead with
stretchy motion and unique smears as
seen all over mob's third episode it's
not something hugely uncommon by today's
standards but it's a style he helped
cultivate and popularize and speaking of
convention typically when an episode of
an animated series is produced the
animators actively tried to stick as
close to the model sheets produced by
the character designers to retain a
consistent look across the series
however episode 3 is intentionally off
model sticking true to one's desire to
allow the animation staff Freedom this
episode where mob contends with the
cultist demonstrates that unbridled
creativity sometimes doing this can
alienate viewers but clearly the staff
saw the beauty in its uniqueness as
common as stepped away from doing any
art Corrections for this one and let the
episode sing untouched other episodes
can offer their unique flares of
Brilliance but nothing quite stands out
quite like the creative choices made for
episode 3. this is all to say that these
three episodes all serve to create a
wonderfully emotional and intense
introduction to this series I've never
in my life seen a story brought to the
Silver Screen with such a profoundly
strong intense sense of direction and
identity when punch Man's first season
truly does stand out as a monument to
how incredibly flashy the talent
residing within Japan can be but mob
psycho 100's introduction here
demonstrates what a unified approach can
offer a production with such enormous
Talent behind it the likes of which
would only be surpassed as time goes on
in episodes 4 and beyond episode 3 is
cultist setting amongst those that were
brainwashed by dimple to smile a time
and again offered the perfect stage for
mop to naturally demonstrate what he can
do and more importantly offered us a
taste of what he's capable of and little
did we know that right around the next
Corner something even more devastating
was awaiting us
Terror vs Mob thematically I think
episode 4 and 5 contends with some of
the core themes of this story and in
many ways deliver some of the best
action we've seen in this series
depending on your tastes and let me tell
you when I was sitting down to digest
this series on day one after having
already been blown away by what the
first three introductory episodes have
offered episode 5 shattered any and all
high expectations I had already had for
this series when watching this episode 5
quickly became my absolute favorite
episode however to think of this as a
single episode's success would be
ignorant as it not only stands in the
shoulders of all the exposition
elegantly delivered to us from the first
three episodes but also stands as one
half of a two episode Arc with the
fourth episode offering up some of the
more introspective elements to what
ultimately becomes one of the best
animated episodes of Television I've
ever seen in my life the human trade or
narrative mechanism take your pick that
more often than not drives the plot
forward in this story is this constantly
from others to push in the direction of
seeking more power more control despite
all the status power or abilities they
may or may not have and to achieve this
they again seek to manipulate directly
or indirectly the odds into their favor
the class bully otherwise called
onigawara is such an individual as we
learn of the criminal or thuggish World
he's vying for greater respect within
similarly there's a new character
introduced called taruki hanizawa or
Teru and he's very much someone to look
out for in mob's case as he seems to
only have everything that mob seems to
want but also happens to be gifted with
psychic abilities just like Bob but
something I'd like to chat about before
we get into the real substance of this
mini Arc is the small story that
facilitates the first moment my
excitement launched me from my chair and
into a fit of laughing and anticipation
as we know mob struggles with Athletics
and physical fitness in addition to
pretty much every other aspect of his
life that isn't linked to his psychic
abilities in episode 2 he volunteered to
join the body Improvement club and
despite it being filled with a group of
conventionally looking bodybuilder types
they are without question the sweetest
and most supportive force in mob's life
presently they do not use him they just
support him as if he was part of the
family despite his clear struggles in
other words they admire his
determination to plant each step in
front of the other simply because he's
trying to better himself and nothing
more that's so awesome it honestly
stands out in this series of
manipulators however In This Very
episode through the manipulation of many
key characters mob is led to an ambush
an ambush that leads the Jim Bros
showing up to save the day and the way
they are depicted in this moment they
arrive it's like the five Horsemen of
the ass whooping apocalypse arrives to
serve them their Collective asses
they're there to save mob it's so funny
and overly dramatic with appropriate
animation and music to emphasize this
it's easily the funniest and most oddly
wholesome moment in the series for me
this is the conversation that reveals
mob's internal philosophy regarding his
powers and his willingness to use them
it's a beautiful and resonant sentiment
that colors not just this mini Arc but
indeed the rest of the series and Beyond
when it was revealed that ritsu his
younger brother wasn't altruistically
considered of mob and secretly harbored
a significant amount of resentment
towards him it by default introduced a
phenomenal extra layer of nuance and
complexity to this seemingly simple and
lighthearted story in this brief but
Illuminating conversation ritsu asks if
there are things he mob can't have if he
chooses to use his psychic abilities and
MOB responds yes
muscles the ability to understand girls
to read his surroundings and get more
wisdom it's been explained and
demonstrated that ritsu has everything
that mob himself wants he's popular and
academically successful and echoing this
reality mob continues to say in return
that he himself is envious of his
brother for being able to do all of that
and in my view this small statement
highlights the key difference in
thinking between mob and the person who
challenges him to an epic showdown later
in this Arc
foreign
versus mob is what many might consider
to be the action highlight of this
season though I would personally argue
it's but one of many it's an amazing
season that said it is a stupendous
spectacle to Bear witness to If ever
there was one and is driven entirely by
character motivations making it all the
more emotionally compelling a
well-defined character is one that's
capable of making decisions that are
consistent with what we understand are
their goals and beliefs of that
established character this is why we
find characters like Captain America
compelling why Tony Stark is a thrill to
watch and even why Vegeta all the way
through Dragon Ball Z was captivating to
follow because we knew what his thought
process would be and when he makes
decisions it's captivating when
characters make decisions that run
counter to their beliefs that's when our
immersion is shattered and we start to
scrutinize the script and thankfully the
opposite is true for the Great Character
writing moments which is why in my
opinion divorce from all the action
thrilling music and animation this fight
is fundamentally on a written word
brilliant not just because I enjoyed the
characters but because mob and Tarot in
this instance represent opposing answers
to a certain philosophical question that
this show is asking and that question is
should you use your powers for your
benefit whether they be Supernatural or
not and MOB says no Teru says yes and
this fight more than just a Clashing of
powers and fists is a battle of ideals
and whoever wins will likely change the
other fundamentally forever
interestingly the very existence of
tarot as a character highlights that mob
if he so chose to compromise his ideals
could have everything he so clearly
wants and yearns for Teru uses his
powers to manipulate people to scare
larger and more intimidating people to
do his bidding and can even leverage his
abilities to heighten his physical
prowess all areas we thought mob just
lacked in are now areas we can see he
chooses not to utilize because as
pointed out in the last episode those
that choose to use their positions or
powers for selfish Desires in an unfair
manner are often blind to the
shortcomings those shortcuts often open
them up to and as we see with tarot
oftentimes can lure them into believing
that they are a God above all scrutiny
and competition and hilariously but also
fittingly Reagan is the one who helped
to instill that particular outlook on
life for Bob and when I learned that I
didn't know quite what to think and in
truth it made me like and enjoy Reagan
even more than I was already doing if
that was even possible
it's absolutely possible and it happens
at the end that I'm definitely gonna
talk about it but back on topic this
fight is amazing mob might be an
oblivious character but the author One
sure does know how to write dimwits with
strong moral characters this is such a
wonderful scene and the dismantling of
terror's Life philosophy is scathing we
are the same he says without the powers
you're an average loser just like me
with the only difference being mob has
the courage to navigate his world and
life without them the physical
transformation that Terror undergoes as
he slowly loses his mind fighting mob is
brilliant to say also and not to mention
hilarious and perfectly when Terry
resorts to attacking mob with his bare
hands he actually makes contact and
chokes him to the point where he mob
begins to let his Consciousness slip
away and as a result we're building to
an explosion when
what a wimpy punch but this very gesture
despite it being so weak is the heaviest
philosophical blow thrown in this battle
of ideals for despite the dire
circumstances he refuses to use his
powers this is what moral conviction
looks like not doing things because they
are easy but doing them because they are
the right thing to do in that moment
despite being difficult if he hadn't
already this is the moment where I
believe mob gained the respect of
literally everyone else watching along
at home
skull and I
[Music]
look like come on
from this point on we're offered
glimpses into the past where he and his
brother as little kids were ambushed by
thugs mob blacks out and when he awakens
their bodies are strewn across the
street with blood everywhere this is a
formative time in his life one that I'm
sure impacted mob's fear concerning his
powers and their outright use in
day-to-day life but I think this most
importantly demonstrates something for
us to notice something we haven't seen
from mob's prior explosions in those
moments he may have exploded with power
always looking amazing however he always
also seemed to be in control but this
flashback to a traumatic event he shared
with his brother shows something else an
instance in time where mob truly blacks
out and someone else takes the wheel
in this scene the tone shifts from the
shallow philosophical battle that Terror
was forcing mob to engage in to an
all-out fight for survival as mob loses
all control and a distinctly different
almost ever written atmosphere takes
hold and refuses to relinquish control
until everything before him is left in
ruin flinging Terror naked and half the
school into the sky above the clouds
when he eventually returns to his senses
he realizes what he's done cries and
laments the fact that perhaps he hasn't
changed since that day after all from an
animation standpoint episode 5 is
absurdly good this is all from the mind
of Konichi fujisawa who storyboarded
this directed it and was its animation
director also he is one of the big names
in the quote web gen movement this
movement refers to a young group of
people who came up in the mid-2000s
learning to animate on tablets and using
software like flash helping their work
feel distinctly different in an industry
that even to this day primarily uses
pencils and paper for animation and much
like episode 3 there's a distinct focus
on movement with character rigidity and
model correctness thrown out the window
in favor of big idiosyncratic Styles
which as it happens is a defining
Cornerstone of webgen animation and
you've seen fujisawa's work already most
likely having made a name for himself on
Naruto animating one of the most iconic
parts of Kakashi vs Obito having also
taken part in other ambitious projects
like Full Metal Alchemist Milos movie
and Space Dandy looking at these two
Productions he's always been drawn to
projects that try to do something
different and MOB fits that building 280
and impressively this was his debut as
far as having 100 creative control over
the storyboard and animation Direction
tachikawa gave him all of the freedom
and this led to a fight that's extended
in length far beyond what the manga
initially offered including hilarious
new visual gags enjoy and wonderfully
this demonstrates an understanding for
what one said he was hoping the anime
would do with his series I'm sure when
he watched this episode he had a massive
dumb smile on his face in addition to
that the legendary norio Matsumoto who
many will know for defining so much of
battle shown in action in the late 90s
and early 2000s is here he was a massive
influence in fujisawa's work over the
years which makes the fact that they
eventually made friends and joins forces
on this project and almost fairy
tale-like ending for the duo and it
doesn't even stop there this episode has
so much care and thought put into its
production that the quality even seeps
into the Sound and Music design mob's
theme entitled mob's emotional explosion
is without a doubt the centerpiece of
the entire musical score for this show
so let's try to break it down for a
second driving the piece is the only
trace of percussion you will hear for a
lot of the track a kick drop hitting
every single beat this really propels
the entire piece with a sense of energy
almost like a frantic heartbeat you also
have a piano and a synth accompanying
this throughout the track though they
are mixed pretty well in favor of the
star of the show
that instrument
what even is that
is it a kazoo America what is that
oh it's this this instrument is called a
sea moons it sounds wrong to say and by
instrument I guess I really mean robot
Abomination with artificial lungs and
throat capable of making that weird
kazoo-like singing we hear this thing
was invented by meiwa denki who was
actually the inventor of the automatone
this dude is a literal music Willy Wonka
who invents gun sense instruments as he
so calls them and so Kenji Kawai the guy
behind the OST 4 mob psycho 100 seems to
have a particular interest in Sea moons
in particular as this is not even the
first time he uses one in his work
and contracted denki for the production
of mob psycho 100 score this instrument
brings such an incredibly unique flavor
to this piece there really is a sense of
profound power and Terror that is
conveyed with its musical output which
certainly makes sense given how
terrifying the instrument that carves
out the song looks
ritsu and MOB having explored what it
means to have powers and to use them
responsibly to improve yourself using
your own abilities we find ourselves now
delving into a story that contends with
the opposite side of that argument we
now know what one ought to pursue if
they have powers but what if they don't
what if their lives are comparatively
perfect but they remain fixated on what
they perceive is a lacking in their life
this is the story of Bob and his younger
brother ritsu and their dynamic in these
episodes might be the most compelling
element of this entire story so far
because quite simply they are both
characters that don't find Value in what
makes them intrinsically special but
instead feel worthless by focusing on
what they're not with compliments from
his brother mob like ritsu is much more
talented than I am and doesn't do
anything weird ringing like an insult in
his younger brother's ears and because
of this attention to detail concerning
these characters when you plot them into
this Fantastical world and allow the
narrative to be driven by them and the
believable human choices they make it
not only makes for entry retaining
reading and watching but creates a
captivating Story the likes of which I
honestly could not look away from
[Music]
early on with ritsu I was convinced he
was a simple and kind younger brother
however since then he has evolved to a
comparatively far more complex
believable jealous and well resentful
younger sibling that has far more in
common now with his older brother than
he might think just not in the areas he
personally cares for at this moment
detached from that for a moment the
framing of onigoara is an interesting
way for ritsu and Shinji to express
their non-conforming or authentic selves
so to speak it's all a balance of those
who framed on the gowara leveraging
their power or reputation to harass and
frame someone who comparatively has less
social Credit in other words ritsu and
Shinji in this instance are in this
scene making the same mistake and
metaphorically doing exactly as Teru did
in the last episode abusing their power
with them leveraging their strengths to
prevent him from using what he's good at
is fighting and honestly a lesser show
would stop there and focus on their a
plot but brilliantly one offers
onigawada something else he uses this as
a lesson to teach the character taking
this as a signal that while yes onigo
water himself he was wrongfully accused
and his name was destroyed by these
people wrongfully it was his lack of
care to his other attributes that
created the perfect set of dominoes to
fall should the correct situation arise
and that's such a subtle nuanced and
Brilliant lesson for someone a kid
potentially watching this to take away
from this whole show However
unfortunately ritsu his lesson isn't so
easily learned for once his anguish over
not having powers gets the better of him
he soon realizes that he may have powers
when he sees for the very first time
what's up dimple as an interesting
ruffle to this unfolding Story the
surrounding gangs of this greater
territory the world of mob psycho 100 is
set in have bore witness to the
terrifying power of mob without actually
knowing who that in fact was and this
secures the reasonable level of
uncertainty that makes the following
chapters all the more interesting
because at some point due to his abuse
of power ritsu will gain the attention
of someone he really isn't ready for
it's Teru cosplaying as Marge Simpson I
I think a pineapple either way he's not
ready for this cat either but what's
awesome is that Teru now stands as a
monument to the good that mob can bring
to people he's completely changed his
Outlook and as a reformed man he
recognizes the same sort of trouble
appearing in bitsu following him all the
way down in Alleyway where he's
confronted by an army of thugs ready to
fight who they think is Mob his brother
and really this outing here is just to
show the progression and downfall of
ritsu the evolution or progression of
his powers but the downfall of his
ideals as a character the destruction
he's rod on this group of trouble kids
is unsettling and in the eyes of one
individual it's more unsettling than
anything else
I
um
I spoke earlier in this video about the
two most famous characters one as an
author has created in sayatama and Ma
respectively and how they differ from
one another while sharing many key part
of how their stories are written in
common however I think taking a closer
look at the fundamental differences
between these two now iconic characters
will shine a light largely on what
substance is at the core of this
phenomenal scene and what I believe mob
is when comparing these two characters
potentially the most relatable mob and
sayatama are most different in that they
are driven by different themes around
their similar situations they are both
wildly strong characters that dwarf
everyone around them neither are
particularly intelligent and have to of
course contend with the mundinity of
Life despite their supernatural
abilities however at his core sayatama
from one punch man is ultimately an
exploration into the question if you
manage to become great or the best then
what what more is there delving into the
Practical and emotional consequences of
achieving exactly what you set out to
achieve in other words in the specific
case of sayatamas is being better than
everyone else worth it on the flip side
to the character avmob he is an
exploration of what the best even means
in the first place thus being the best
or strongest psychic of all time matter
if you're miserable and can't make
friends and to that same end considering
the point of view of ritsu thus being
the most academically successful or
popular kid at school matter if you
can't do what you want in ritu's case
it's being psychic but this question can
easily be posed to anyone and highlight
their weaknesses whether they be getting
good grades doing well in sports or what
have you the dichotomy of what people
have versus what they want with the
potential results or findings of that
thesis being that there isn't a best
thing to be good at because asmob has
gone to Great Lengths to explain being
special at one thing doesn't make you
any better of a person than the man next
to you sucks at that this as I alluded
to earlier is highlighted in mobs heart
to heart with his brother in episode 4
and further reinforced through his
battle with tarot in other words mob is
forced to Grapple with and evolve from
the carrot he has been dealt in life it
just so happens that hand he's been
dealt is being the absolute best psychic
of all time and sucking complete ass at
literally everything else and I think
it's for that very reason why mob
resonates with those that take the time
to watch this series so easily a sense
of connection is formed to the character
of mob that I think is even stronger
than that which one punch Man
establishes simply because that theme
that Bob himself as a character
represents is so much more relatable
every single one of us has something
that we believe we are exceptionally
good at and we all have aspects about
ourselves that we find deeply
unsatisfactory finding our personal
worth among those elements is so hard
but mob is living proof that pushing
yourself outside of your comfort zone to
strive for goals that don't come easy to
improve yourself are always worth it and
this is what I love about one's writing
on its face it presents as a gag manga
with little else to be expected from it
aside from some some supremely well
crafted comedy but when you least expect
it to it can profoundly reach across the
screen and give you a wonderfully
emotional and enriching experience the
likes of which are seldom seen in this
genre
this fight for the fate of ritsu is
utterly and dumbfoundingly gorgeous the
movement the framing the dramatic camera
work the awesomeness that mob is
emanating with the greatest of these is
spectacular and interestingly this scene
brought to my attention something I
honestly should have noticed sooner
mechanically mob's action scenes are fun
for the same reasons Gohan's action
scenes are in early Dragon Ball Z they
are both innocent and unassuming
characters that want nothing more than a
peaceful resolution driven to a Breaking
Point they didn't want to reach before
finally erupting in an incredible show
of force even some of the framing of mob
in this scene feels reminiscent of
Dragon Ball Z at times to me which is
more than okay however for the first
time in this series mob has a lot more
in his table here than might meet the
eye and due to that we're shown a sign
of him that we've only seen once before
a terrifying set of powers that engulfed
the thoughtful and kind personality of
the young mob and in a devastating
series of attacks heavy and precise ones
that border on difficult to look at at
times Ma job is eventually outsmarted
leaving his unconscious body still
animating itself in a further unsettling
fashion struggling for consciousness
of these three episodes that make up
this section there's really only one
that possesses animation and direction I
felt I needed to touch on and it's
episode 8. it is it might be my favorite
episode I don't know and you know what
I'm leaning into the meme this might be
the best episode I've watched in the
series so far
after two smaller episodes mob's insane
production value returns in full force
and the show's character designer
yoshimichi kamaida takes the Reigns once
again as animation director with a
storyboard that features heavy
contributions from the series director
tachikawa you can feel kamada's expert
and confident touches all over this
episode from the sketchy Line work to
the awesome poses it's unmistakably
comedy furthermore this episode is
packed to bursting with an enormous
number of insanely talented animators
the extent to which could very well be
its own Standalone video but perhaps the
most important inclusion here is bones's
SuperStar one of the most influential
animators to ever exist with hundreds of
people now animating his distinct impact
frames and cubic debris it is of course
Yutaka Nakamura
it cannot be overstated just how iconic
influential and immensely talented this
man is whether you know him by name or
not you've no doubt seen him in shows
like my hero Academia and one punch man
and go further back and you'll see him
in Cowboy Bebop heck you might even have
seen scenes that you thought were him
but were in fact just inspired by his
legendary work Nakamura is seen in this
episode is absurd not only is he drawing
insane character motion but the guy is
also animating building exteriors and
Interiors they're such a wonderful sense
of momentum and weight to his movements
that elevates this scene to Heights they
otherwise wouldn't reach without him
he's a master of his craft in full force
in this episode which after mob dimple
and Terror ready themselves to retrieve
ritsu from the clutches of this evil
organization of proficient psychics sets
up nicely for the final but incredible
Arc of this season
claw
let me tell you while I absolutely loved
every single episode in this season
nothing could have prepared me for how
remarkable this last stretch of episodes
was with the introduction of the class
7th division the stakes are immediately
raised we've spent the entire show so
far feeling safe because we know that
mob is there and stronger than anyone
else but the situation we find ourselves
in now is unlike anything we've come
across before this group of powerful
evil adult psychics has kidnapped Ritu
as well as all of the Awakening lab kids
and MOB is not there to squash the
baddies before any harm can come to them
of course it doesn't take long before
mob and Tara come face to face with one
of claw's bosses and 12 seconds of child
sanctioned waterboarding later they have
all they need to head to claw HQ except
they don't seem to believe any of the
info that a claw boss has given up and
watching this guy dangle upside down
completely failing to explain that he
has told him effectively everything
already is so damn funny and really
highlights another one of the strong
suits of this show the sound design all
of the sound design around every Punch
Kick a use of psychic ability Works to
deliver the adaptation in a convincing
and gripping manner but I think one
aspect that really shines Above the Rest
here is the use of a sound effect to
elevate a certain element of the show
The cowbell that strikes as we are shown
updates a mob's percentage is a
recurring example but the way that they
are used to highlight the comedy really
cannot be understated either the hard
cut to the perplexed claw boss with the
bell sound effect ringing out has got to
be one of the hardest laughs I have got
from the entire show little touches like
that are throughout the sound work in
the anime and I think it's a worse show
without them while various mob and Tarot
hijinks are going on we are treated to
ritsu and KO being locked up by easily
the scariest claw member of the bunch I
mean seriously Jesus this guy's face and
voice are something I wish I could go
back in on C and on here the entire
sequence is honestly so very chilling to
watch and it's actually the first time
we've seen any harm actually come to the
humans in this show much less a kid and
with it we see The Return of our beloved
paint on glass animator Mio Sato to
really drive home the chilling nature of
it all but from this we get what I think
is probably the best ritsu moment of the
entire season Once daichi the other
circle-headed twin lets everyone know
that his brother's death was actually
just a psychic illusion Ritu takes the
concocting an actual Escape Plan and
this Escape really highlights so many of
my favorite elements of these final
episodes because it's not ritsu's new
psychic powers the ones that he's been
painfully longing for his entire life
that saves the day here well not
completely at least it's his natural
talents his cunning intelligence and
social skills that allows him to utilize
every single kid there and execute a
Flawless escape plan it didn't matter
how strong he'd become or save the day
in the end was what made him unique from
the get-go and that's really the theme
that stays with us for the rest of this
season Once mob Taro and dimple who is
now possessing some poor claw crony make
their way inside claw HQ they are
quickly met by koyama aka the lip ring
guy that fought mob and kidnap 32 in the
first place and let me just say as soon
as I saw this rematch lined up man I was
prepared I was ready for another epic
mob Throwdown except um
yeah yikes none of them are messing
around in fact the entire episode
revolves around mob and crew splitting
up in search of ritsu and man is that
episode fun this entire mini Arc has so
much more of an ensemble cast feel to it
than anything we've seen so far and it's
just a blast to watch as we bounce back
and forth between dimple and his stolen
body Shenanigans tarot competently
dealing with the terrifying espresso
sent his way and MOB well we actually
don't get to see much of mob fighting in
fact these poor claw bosses are up
against mob with no concern for holding
back so most of them don't even last
long enough to Warrant being defeated on
screen apparently and honestly seeing
mob completely and utterly decimate
everyone in front of him isn't even
really scary at this point it's almost
euphoric a major Drive of this entire
story thus far has been the slow buildup
of mob's emotions and power over time
the small bits of release as he explodes
but now we are going to see him cut
loose and damn if there isn't something
satisfying about just one-shotting every
single scar he comes up against playing
even more into that ensemble cast
element both dimpled Ontario end up
running into their own scars to deal
with Terror runs up against miyagawa a
full-blown pyrotechnic who actually
manages to put Terror against the ropes
by engulfing him in Flames hironori
Tanaka who many people might know from
chainsaw man's crazy third episode
tackles the brunt of this action
sequence and man is at an absolute treat
he'd almost sweat just looking at it
dimple similarly runs into matsuo
another scar who keeps powerful pet
spirits to eviscerate his foes and all
of this bouncing back and forth between
fights creates Within These episodes and
almost monster of the week type Vibe
with the wide variety of enemies offered
up to us all at once there is however
definitely a bit of an uneasy feeling in
these fights as just the same way ritsu
and KO are in the enemy territory absent
of mob's protection so too now are
dimple and Terror and while we do have
decent confidence in their strengths and
abilities there is still this creeping
feeling of danger as they face
increasingly stronger foes alone because
as we've been reminded time and again
throughout this series the full weight
of this Mission success rests on whether
or not mob can win the day the rest of
them in our eyes this can help but they
also just need to survive dimples fight
with matzo is definitely the first and
most prominent example of this as he is
largely outgunned and outmatched against
these full power Spirits he's up against
dimple is such an incredibly enjoyable
character to watch so seeing him manage
to outwit his enemies by possessing
unpossessing and then repossessing his
borrowed body to get the enemy away from
him is a whole lot of fun but expertly
plays into this character at least until
we learned that matsuo has more pets
still and seals dimple away in a jar
crammed full of the hungry bunch and
with that momentum shift so too is tarot
also taken out by a tag team of claws
that catch him off guard it's at this
point the stress noticeably starts to
build in the story and so as not only
dimple and Terror are both captured but
ritsu and Company also run into and are
swiftly taken out by show a powerful
young psychic who apparently isn't even
a member of claw's 7th division but a
visiting intern what's this kid's deal
anyway I don't know I'm sure it won't
matter later on as the episode heads
towards a close and MOB dispatches yet
another few scars both on and off screen
he also discovers and knocked out ritsu
on the ground following his fight to
show at this point the light-hearted bad
guys swatting Vibe of the Minier comes
to an end and in its place is a very
real palpable sense of Terror already
grappling with a crippling sense of
grief and depression mob is ambushed by
the same claw member that showed the
Awakening lab crew visions of their
members death and in that very same way
he shows mob visions of ritsu's
terrifying graphic bloody demise mob has
dealt with a lot of stress in this
season so far much of it has been too
much for him to take and has resulted in
the incredible yet terrifying explosions
we are now accustomed to seeing but this
one this one is different as the
percentiles struggle to avoid reaching
100 the climax is not one of Rage or
even Furious violence it is something
entirely different as we see flashed on
screen rejection mob perhaps out of pure
subconscious defense completely rejects
what he is seeing and reflects all of
his fear remorse stress and power back
onto Muto leaving both him and mob
completely unconscious and injured the
scream that mob lets out here is without
a doubt my favorite bit of acting in the
entire season his scream and the way it
is mixed and layered is so raw and
chilling it blows me away every single
time I take a look at it and with that
the stage is set the Awakening lab kids
dimple every single one of our
protagonists are defeated or unconscious
locked away in a room that inhibits all
psychic powers there is no one left and
certainly no one's strong enough to take
down claw they've lost
oh
yeah
oh yeah Reagan's here
say the line mark
this episode is the best mob episode
I've ever seen
it fires on all cylinders delivering
every single element of the series
flawlessly and it's all because of one
man Reagan arataka the greatest cycle to
ever live I mentioned this before but
Reagan is unlike any character I've ever
seen in anime sure there are other
characters that have a similar Vibe of
fake it till you make it I mean Mr Satan
hell even came from one's own one punch
man is but Reagan is different because
as this episode makes abundantly clear
to the surprise of every single viewer
Reagan is the real deal
not in that he was harboring Supreme
powers of any description no it's
actually something we've seen from the
start that Reagan is really really good
at talking
Reagan is as good at talking arguing and
convincing people as mob is at being a
psychic and in truth even though this is
the second to last episode of the season
this episode is in fact the climax of
the story and in this Grand Finale that
is later packed with tension action and
emotional climaxes the first half of the
episode is composed almost exclusively
of Reagan making me laugh out loud I'm a
grown man sitting in my living room
laughing at my TV for like 15 minutes
straight at an anime character
inadvertently convincing an entire evil
organization he is their Leader by
accident this show man this show is
perfect
with everyone defeated and locked away
Reagan arrives on the scene by following
mob's phone GPS coordinates because of
course he is and as he Walters up to the
Brigade of claw cronies at the door it
doesn't take long before his confidence
and blunt Nature has managed to convince
the entire group that he is in fact the
leader of claw and as he's escorted in
he then stops the clock runs from
attacking the discovered Awakening kids
by letting them know that kidnapping
kids and being violent is wrong and
again the level of catharsis I felt
watching Reagan just completely owned
this entire organization with his words
and confidence alone Rivals the feeling
of watching mob one shot someone and
once Reagan reaches where mob is being
held he quickly dismisses all the grunts
by explaining to them that what they are
doing is actually a crime and they're
off on their merry way what's that you
say I've only been talking about Reagan
for the last three minutes correct
what's your point in seriousness though
the back half of this episode is somehow
even more remarkable than the first as
Reagan and MOB finally run into their
remaining claw scars Spirit Pokemon
trainer NAPA NAPA Samurai businessman
and Tiny gas mask girl who is the leader
of claw's seventh division somehow and
so Begins the true central conflict of
the rest of the season in a show sojam
packed with action comedy wonderful bits
of Animation every single element that
can be going for a show like this the
true conflict of this final mini Arc
isn't a big cinematic fight it isn't mob
hitting 100 and destroying everything in
his path rather it is Reagan wanting to
make sure that mob knows using powers
against others is wrong with four
separate scars directly threatening the
lives of his mentor family and friends
mob is so desperately backed into the
corner of being an anime protagonist and
fighting back but despite all of that
Reagan continues to insist that mob
shouldn't I find this core emotional
conflict so enthralling and not at all
what I expected going into this show we
all know that Mob Could wipe all four of
these people off the face of the Earth
without so much as a second thought but
should he he's just a kid a literal
middle schooler who hasn't even figured
out how to get his Crush to notice him
so often when we sit and watch shows
like this I think we tend to Discount
the reality of the situation
rationalizing it away as being necessary
or what other choice do they have but
Reagan rejects that entirely he walks
into this Arc Uninvited looks all
straight in the face and says are you
crazy these are kids and the hardest
part is it's difficult to say what is
right at this point because yes mob is
just a kid but he's a kid who is about
to be brutally murdered along with
everyone he knows if he doesn't fight
back does not hurting others with your
powers really weren't letting that
happen it's all happening so fast how is
Mob supposed to figure this out well
Reagan doesn't really give him a chance
to figure it out while everyone is
distracted trying to take mob out Reagan
whips out another one of his special
techniques this time in the form of a
simple drop kick to the leader ishiguru
and punching muraki in the face which
actually works surprisingly well at
least for long enough to let him talk
some more but unfortunately Lee Reagan
miscalculated here his plan to knock
some sense into these adults and take
them out of murdering actual children
means nothing when he's up against these
people they aren't really adults they're
practically grown children stuck in
Arrested Development still fighting
their battles and aiming for their goals
with fists and Blades so with all of
them completely ignoring Reagan's words
the big battle of the season commences
and wow what a battle this is this
entire show is incredibly animated but
perhaps nowhere is that as a parent as
these final fights in fact by the time
this episode was airing the entire anime
had wrapped up its production and
completed now that might not sound like
all that much of a feat since there's
only one episode left but unfortunately
almost all anime are run on a painfully
tight schedule so the fact that this
anime managed to wrap up production
entirely before its penultimate episode
even airs is remarkable to me this
episode also marks the entrance of what
a mob psycho 100's most prolific names
in its production hakuyu go tackling
multiple long cuts in both of the major
fights here he was 24 years of age when
this was made and had only just joined
the industry two years prior I mean how
do you even begin to talk about
something like that the background
animation the effects work and the
nakamura-esque inspired full drawn
environment I mean it's just absurd 24
years old let me remind you and while I
haven't watched it yet it is my
understanding that he is here to stay
going forward with mob psycho as an
absolute Powerhouse of a contributor to
this production as the fights continue
to progress Teru ritsu and Reagan
continue to lose ground and become more
in danger as tarot continues to call out
mob begging him to fight back for real
to save them all insurmountable pressure
then starts to build with each blow
traded in the background mob stress and
conviction grows further if he doesn't
do something they're all going to die
Reagan desperately pleads to mob to not
fight back
but they can't run they're all fending
off deadly attacks from powerful
psychics Reagan pleads one last time
don't fight against someone with
murderous intent
from all of this with nowhere else to
turn no choices left to make mob is
backed into a corner and as Mio sato's
absolutely remarkable painting glass
animation returns once again mob makes
his choice
oh
foreign
this moment is genuinely for me the
climax of the entire season the hard
caught from the build up of the music
and visuals surrounding mob's rage and
acceptance of murderous attempt to
Reagan smack him in the face and setting
him straight is absolutely Flawless
every single element presented to us
indicates that we were about to see mob
completely cut loose and showcase all of
his powers to us in a fantastic
demonstration of raw power and rage I
mean it's nearing the climax of the
anime of course it will and there's
plenty of Precedence set for this to
create our anticipation but with one
slap from Reagan every single element of
this anticipation is hard cut away from
in a single frame Reagan has managed to
cut through all of this and get it
through to mob and us as an audience and
later the rest of the people in the room
that this is all meaningless violence
and not how children should act the
entire scene is so incredibly subversive
of what you would expect from an anime
and the audio and visuals execute on
that completely flawlessly what a show
it is such a shock beautiful piece of
television and it couldn't have
concluded any other way really every
single action in this entire season
every character conflict surrounding mob
every piece of Reagan wackiness it all
comes collapsing in on a singular moment
and the flashback that follows we see
the very first time that mob beats
Reagan and Reagan plainly lays out the
central thesis of this entire season
just because you have psychic powers
doesn't make you any less human the same
goes for people who can run fast or are
smart or even who stink we all have
characteristics that define us and in
the end they are not what Define us what
matters is embracing who you are being
kind to others and becoming a good
person what a powerful theme what an
incredible message not just for the
child in distress here but for all of us
sizzle
foreign
much to my surprise the beginning of the
final episode doesn't begin with a giant
mob explosion but rather a quiet
realization that mob doesn't have to
fight that running is also an option at
which point Reagan leaps up from the
ground scolding The Swordsman for trying
to hurt him with a toy sword
um what well as we quickly begin to
realize it would appear in the stress
and emotional release of the moment
prior mob inadvertently projected his
100 or should I say one thousand percent
power into Reagan in sort of a flight or
flight response and boy oh boy does
Reagan put it to good use what follows
is a highly entertaining sequence of
Reagan Shenanigans completely
dismantling the psyches and beliefs of
these scars this power trip is so fun to
watch and at this point Reagan may as
well be the main character and once
again he manages to utterly Blindside Me
by putting into perspective what is
actually happening here these people
that think that they're special capable
of ruling the world with their strength
but they're not everyone is good at
something being a strong psychic isn't
going to make them popular hurting
others isn't going to fix Sakurai the
swordsman's traumatic childhood of dead
parents and Foster home abuse in fact as
Reagan describes he too had a tragic
childhood
one time he was young he forgot to tell
his parents that it was sports day at
school so he didn't have anything to eat
for lunch that particular day
foreign
despite the insanity of all of this
Reagan seems to manage to convince all
of the claws though it was mob's power
that facilitated his actions it was
actually his approach in Charisma that
made the difference all but their leader
ishiguro who as it turns out is oh dear
God he's a wrinkly old man make it go
away with Reagan's Powers run out and
MOB exhausted ishiguro's final tantrum
which surely spelled Doom for them all
if it wasn't for the fact the climax
happened last episode that is so as it
happens show that intern kid from a few
episodes back is actually the claws
Leader's kid and was checking up on the
seventh division the entire time
promptly putting an end to ishiguro and
caps off the combat disappointed however
in mob's decision to run the rest of
this episode is a sequence of really
cozy tie-ops and check-ins on all of her
characters mob is glad to be back at
school with his crushed the gym Bros
continue to be sick as all hell and Taro
is ready to lead the Awakening lab kids
onto higher highs Reagan able to see
dimple now is happy to have another
helper at his side and looming over the
distance claws leader seems to approach
if it isn't clear already I think this
resolution this Arc and well really this
whole season are utterly brilliant those
of you who watch my channel often enough
know that I'm not always this positive
about the works that I watch or read but
there is a reason I am now this show
delivers on every possible front the
story animation music sound design
compositing editing storyboarding
everything is working in tandem to bring
you this wonderful story and characters
in the best way it possibly can and the
story that we do get in the end is 100
worth that Herculean effort I have
watched a lot of anime and read a lot of
manga for this channel as well as in my
personal time across my whole life some
I've liked some not so much but it has
been quite some time since I so deeply
enjoyed watching an anime like this the
characters and themes it delivers are
remarkably genuine thoughtful and
enthralling and I can't wait for what
season two has in store for me
in the end the core motivation behind my
wanting to explore this series in
Greater detail was that I wanted to try
to make sense of why or how someone like
one became successful as a mangaka over
the years in reviewing these stories
from the East Miami has been to uncover
the footprints or fingerprints each and
every artist invariably leaves on their
work as I read them whether it be the
rebellious nature of Iraqi in JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure the pain and anguish
left behind by Togashi and hunter hunter
or even the initially sad but
inspirational journey of Kishimoto
through the likes of his Naruto series
normally people tend to have a
superficial reaction to one's work
because of how it looks on the surface
more so than any other successful
mangaka out there one's work tends to be
initially dismissed with those that are
not open to understanding how it reads
or how his work Works making up a common
part of one's experience trying to make
it as an artist in this industry however
true to the lessons he's learned and
almost exactly like the stories he's
written the crude looking mangas and the
silly stories he presents often have far
more going on right beneath the surface
than one might expect but once you do
notice it that's the moment that one not
only wins you over as a fan but
potentially if you're lucky changes your
outlook and approach to life for the
better and so before I finish this
episode I'd like to share a quote with
you nearing the end of a particular
conversation an interviewer says what he
takes away from Mob psycho 100 is that
you can truly grow up without
interacting with other people further
adding that he doesn't recall any other
manga that puts so much care into
depicting one's own personal growth in
response to these observations one
explains his approach towards mob psycho
100. what I have in mind is to tell a
big story of one little step I don't
believe our lives change completely for
the better at a short notice it's all
the small progress we make that's
important that's what I think while
drawing this manga
[Music]